these serbian nationalists are staging a
pro-russian car rally in belgrade
they're on russian president vladimir
putin's side
we're here because of russia
fight nazism
nazism was not exterminated in 1945
it has survived and must be destroyed
they're convinced that putin is doing
just that fighting nazism in ukraine
the letter z adorns many cars here the
same as can be found on russian army
vehicles it stands for the phrase for
victory
like most serbians nabosha radulavish
rejects these nationalists and the war
even so he feels a strong connection to
russia and has long perceived nato as a
threat he was a teenager when his native
belgrade was bombed during the kosovo
war
i was 14 and in eighth grade but instead
of figuring out which high school to go
to we were preoccupied with trying to
survive the bombings
to this day there are still ruins in
central belgrade a grim reminder of the
war
radulavish says the bombings destroyed
more than bridges and residential
buildings they also undermined his trust
in the west and its values
and he says many here feel similarly
russia's influence in serbia meanwhile
grew stronger over the years putin is
currently on almost every front page
many serbians view russians as their
slavic brothers
russia is admired
and few criticize its war against
ukraine
i think this war has been inevitable for
a long time
the west is hypocritical especially
western media that report on it
we are the largest balkan nation we
should feel the greatest responsibility
one group with a long history of
fighting for civil and human rights are
the women in black
but few join their protest against the
war in ukraine
the activists said the low turnout was
sobering
they believe it was linked to the fact
that many serbians long for a strong
leader rather than a true democracy
do serbians like russia or putin
what they like are authoritarian
governments
that has nothing to do with russia per
se
not long ago german foreign minister
annalena berbach visited serbian
president alexander vucic the meeting
was tense as vucic is known for his
close ties to putin since the war broke
out vujic has attempted a political
balancing act approving a u.n resolution
condemning the russian invasion yet
refusing to carry western sanctions
against the country
what are we supposed to distance
ourselves from
in what sense are we connected to the
conflict in ukraine
what did serbia do wrong
serbia is not talking about anyone not
bringing up any names there is no love
or hate
when it comes to us we only respect
international law
is currently campaigning to be
re-elected in april and polls suggest he
and his party are set to win
most serbians share his view on the
ukraine war
in tosh maidan park in central belgrade
this monument commemorates the children
killed during nato attacks on the city
memories of that old war are still alive
serbia russia we are not in this war but
the u.s england france they need to
recognize how it came to this
i'm against every war
i was against the kosovo war and against
the one before that
i'm against interventions and oppose
using force against independent states
but nebosha radulavish and his friends
say the ukraine war has pushed them to
reassess their long-held loyalty to
russia and critical opinion of nato in
the west
they feel isolated and wonder where that
leaves them and their country serbia
[Music]
we've always been caught in the middle
and that's where we are again now
i'm not sure what difficulties we would
encounter if we were to go along with
sanctions against russia
we just cannot take that road right now
our ties with russia are too strong
economically speaking and there's also
an element of fear
[Music]
their biggest hope is that the war in
ukraine will end soon